Hãy từng đến 15 tuổi tại Ossuê liang Hâm Sautami Mode đã nộp đơn kiện chính phủ
Lên toán tôi cao nhằm chẳng lệnh gấm chảy giới mình sảo tuổi xưa dụng mặt sau hội
Chức khi lọt có hiểu lực từ một mùi mùi tham hay hài vụ kiện giòn bắt động digital freedom project
đứng tên, nhóm cho rằng lệnh gấm của mất cần thiết và lấy đi tưởng nói của dưới chảy
Đồng thời tất đi quyền chào đổi thông tin chính chi, được quy định trong khiến pháp Ossuê liang
Chỉ phủ cao mề ra của tuổi tưởng át tụi đi ở bản phẩm mắt mạnh mẽ và khẳng định không lối bước trước thách thực pháp lý
Bố trường trường thông Anika Wells nói, chỉ phủ đứng về phù hình không phải kên em tạm mà sồi
Đồng thời viện giấm nghiên cứu cho thấy việc làm dụng mặt sau hội thường xuyên gây hại cho thành thường niên với các bệnh nạn như tình ra
Bất nạn trực tình, ác lực hình thệ và thậm chí sẽ quại tầm thần
Truyền thông Ossuê liang của cho biết mà sở hội chiếc xẻ video YouTube cũng xem xét kiet
Nói đào ngược lệnh cấm vì lông gại bị hành trẻ quyền tiếp cận không tìm chi
Các nhà quan sát cho rằng thế giới đào theo dõi sát đổng thái của các bề ra
Khi đây là một trong những nỗ lực quản lý mà sở hội đối với chẻ vì thành nghiên tòa niệm nhát hiện nay
Nếu được át dụng hơn một chậm tại khoảng của mời dưới miếng sau tuổi, sẽ bị sła trên YouTube
Tiktok, Snapchap, Facebook và Instagram